- [Narrator] Winchester Mystery House
in San Jose, California is
one of the most haunted places
in America.
- Winchester Mystery House
is a incredibly unique Victorian mansion
created by Sarah Winchester,
heiress to the Winchester
Repeating Arms fortune.
- [Narrator] Sarah Winchester had a series
of unfortunate things happen to her,
including the death of
her husband and daughter.
She was a spiritualist
and visited a medium
to try and understand why.
- The medium said, well,
the gun that won the west,
there's a lot of karma there, so head west
and build a house to
appease these spirits.
She started construction in 1884,
which didn't stop till the day she died.
The house is a 160 room Victorian mansion
with no master plan.
There's a lot of strange attributes.
There's 40 staircases, 40
fireplaces, four elevators.
We have a number of staircases
that lead right to the ceiling.
Doors that open up into
nothing, or it's just a wall.
- [Narrator] The house
is known for its spirits,
who many people believe
are the ghosts of people
who worked at the house
or even Sarah herself.
- A lot of our guests and employees
have had very strange things
happen to them in this house.
Sometimes it's just
footsteps or hearing a voice,
a light that flickers,
or sometimes it's an actual
full, physical manifestation.
If we haven't solved the
mysteries in 93 years,
then I don't know if we ever will.